okay today I'm going to talk to you
about using a light microscope here is
an image of a light microscope what we
use microscopes for is to be able to
view tiny things it magnifies them so we
can see them in much more detail or even
see things that we wouldn't otherwise be
able to see with the naked eye they're
different from telescopes because
telescopes are used to view really
distant things such as planets or stars
microscopes are used to look at things
that are microscopic very small so um
before we get onto actually using the
microscope if we want to view something
with a microscope first of all we have
to prepare it by putting it onto a slide
now all a slide is is it's a bit of
glass that our sample sits on glasses
it's important that it's glass because
it needs to be transparent so let's say
I have some thin slice of onion really
thin slice of onion and I've put it on
my slide now what I might need I might
need four different it depends on what
I'm looking at but I might need
something called a stain so all a stain
is is a liquid that you can you can drop
on to your sample and it kind of stains
different parts of the cell for example
if you have a set stain called methyl
blue it stains the nuclei so that's all
nuclei remember is just a plural of
nucleus it stains all the nuclei so you
can see them much better
so after you've put the stain on there
you put on this little square of glass
called a coverslip just to keep
everything in place so the coverslip
goes out over the top there and you just
need to press it down to get rid of any
air bubbles as well so then this is
ready your specimen is now ready to be
viewed on the microscope so it's on that
slide so it sits it goes on here now
this particular part here where your
specimen goes you can actually clip it
down with these clips this part here is
called the stage so this is where your
specimen actually sits right here now
it's really important as well that we
turn the microscope on because this part
here at the bottom this part here is the
light so it's important that we have
light shining up through the sample like
this so we can actually be the sample
itself okay
the specimen right the other things that
we need to know the bit that you look
down this part here is called the
eyepiece lens nicer simply it goes with
your eye so this here is the eyepiece
lens that you look down the name of the
other lens is here of the objective lens
objective lenses can you see there's
several different objective lenses all
of them have different strengths of
magnification
some of them have a lower magnification
some have a higher magnification and
also this part here this is called the
focusing wheel so you turn this in order
to bring the image into focus now what
you need to do to begin with once you've
set up your microscope you've got your
specimen ready it's on the stage you
start off with the stage low so you have
it as low as it goes to begin with then
what you do is you choose the objective
lens with the lowest magnification the
weakest magnification out of all of
these what you then do is when that's
all set up and remember your light is on
whilst looking down the eyepiece lens
you turn the focusing wheel bringing up
the stage until it comes into focus so
that means you could see it clearly it's
no longer blurry what you can then do is
a lot of microscopes actually have a
fine focusing wheel as well so the
bigger one here this is the kind of
course focusing to get it pretty much
roughly in focus and this smaller one
here is to get it perfectly focused now
once you've got the image in focus you
can then change the magnification by
changing the objective lens so this part
here just swivels around
and you could pick whichever lens you
want to pick after you've swiveled round
and chose the lens it might need some
more fine focusing in order to get it
and focus but that's essentially it that
is how to use a light microscope
so just to recap you need to put your
specimen on a slide you might need to
stain it so we can see it better under
the microscope and you put on a little
thing called a coverslip it's a bit of
glass that goes over the top that
specimen goes onto the stage which is
this part here of the microscope we
always start with a stage down then
whilst looking through the eyepiece lens
we slowly slowly bring the stage up
until it's into focus in focus sorry
then we always start with a weakest
magnification objective lens want it in
focus that's when we could change the
strength of the objective lens and
that's how to use a light microscope
thank you